hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing an
incredibly scandalous topic why Hermione
should have been with Harry instead of
Ron for those of you who are primarily
fans of the Harry Potter novels or enjoy
both the books and the movies I imagine
that this particular sentiment Sparks
outrage the very mention of the idea on
the other hand for all you movie
loyalists out there I'm fairly certain
many of you are likely nodding your
heads along in agreement and it is for
this exact reason that I'd like to
further Define today's topic so that
there is no confusion on the matter that
is I only believe that Hermione should
have been with Harry in the film
adaptation of the Harry Potter series
now there are exactly three reasons for
why I feel this way and they all revolve
around the Liberties that were taken
with Ron Hermione and Harry's characters
when translating the books into films as
you you may already be familiar with in
the past I've released a series of
videos discussing the major character
differences between these three best
mates when translated from page to
screen if you're not familiar with them
I highly recommend you go check them out
they are three major differences between
book and movie Hermione four huge
differences between movie and book Ron
Weasley and four huge differences about
Harry movie Watchers won't know
essentially in these videos I break down
how both Hermione and Harry are made
into near perfect versions of themselves
especially Hermione whereas Ron is
portrayed as a goofy buffoon version of
his book character for Harry the film
seemed to have removed his Wittier more
rebellious side turning him into a hero
with minimal flaws in the case of
Hermione and Ron the writers simply seem
to have taken away a lot of Ron's lines
and important moments and given them to
Hermione degrading his character and
enhancing her
as I explained in the other videos a
large component of this may have been to
simplify the source of information for
the audience that is by giving Hermione
all of the educational lines in the
movies viewers would clue in that when
Hermione was talking she was often
explaining things about the Wizarding
World in my opinion this was completely
unnecessary and really didn't make all
that much sense for example while in the
books yes Hermione was very intelligent
when it came to book learning it was Ron
who was the source of information on how
the Wizarding World worked this made
great sense since Ron a pure blood
wizard born into a magical family had
lived in this world his entire life
Hermione on the other hand was a
muggle-born witch who had no idea that
the Wizarding World even existed until
she received her letter of acceptance
from Hogwarts in any case I digress but
that's just a little bit of backstory
for you on some of the major differences
between the book and film versions of
these three main characters so with all
this in mind I freely admit that I don't
believe Hermione should have been with
Harry in the novels in fact in the book
series Hermione and Ron are well
actually near perfect for one another
they support one another when it counts
and challenge each other in areas in
which the other has shortcomings plus
Ron's a lot smarter in the book than he
is in the films so he really does keep
up with Hermione's intelligence and
actually rather balances her books marks
with his quick wit humor and Valor this
very clearly is not the case in the
movies a great example of this can be
found in one of the many differences
between scenes in the Prisoner of
Azkaban this particular instance takes
place in professors names potions class
when he asks the third year students a
question in both the book and movie
version Hermione is extremely eager to
respond to the question since of course
she knows the answer Snape however
simply refuses to call on her and so she
shares the the answer with the class
without being asked here's how the rest
of that scene plays out in the novel
that is the second time you've spoken
out of turn Miss Granger said Snape
Cooley five more points from Gryffindor
for being an insufferable know-it-all
Hermione went very red put down her hand
Instead at the floor with her eyes full
of tears it was a mark of how much the
class loathed Snape that they were all
glaring at him because every one of them
had called Hermione a know-it-tool at
least once and Ron who told Hermione she
was a Noah tool at least twice a week
said loudly you asked us a question and
she knows the answer why ask if you
don't want to be told in great contrast
when Hermione shares the answer to
Snape's question out of turn in the
movie and Alan Rickman Snape reprimands
her for being an insufferable
know-it-all do you remember what Rupert
grint's portrayal of Ron says he's got a
point you know I mean no wonder movie
lovers of the Harry Potter franchise
don't think Ron deserves to be with this
flawless and beautiful version of
Hermione as portrayed by Emma Watson not
only is he not that bright but he's also
a complete jerk sadly this sort of Lost
in Translation adaptation from book to
film seems to be quite common as there
are several other scenes in which the
novels portray on as acting in
Hermione's best interest or standing up
for her or Harry but in the movies he's
other rude silent or the scene simply
doesn't exist quite honestly I don't
envy the job the screenwriters were
tasked with when writing all seven Harry
Potter scripts cutting 5 to 800 page
books down into two hour movies would be
no easy task but I simply don't agree
with many of these script changes that
fundamentally altered Ron's relationship
with Hermione and that's not to say
anything about what it did to his
friendship with Harry I mean our movie
Ron and Harry even best friends it
doesn't really seem so does it there are
also multiple scenarios that the films
portray that never take place in the
books many of which make it seem like
Hermione and Harry would be much better
suited for one another than Hermione and
Ron for example in the movie version of
the Half-Blood Prince we see Harry
comforting a crying Hermione in one of
the towers at Hogwarts as you may recall
she's crying in the scene because she's
upset that Ron is dating lavender Brown
and while bookron may have also dated
lavender Brown we are never presented
with the scene in which Hermione cries
on Harry's shoulder in fact he seems to
only notice that she's been crying in
passing with descriptions from the book
sounding something more like this Harry
thought he had a swamp before the door
slammed there's also that scene at the
end of the Half Blood Prince when all
three friends are still at Hogwarts and
Harry is sharing that he doesn't plan on
returning to Hogwarts the following year
and will instead be tracking down
Voldemort's horcruxes in an effort to
defeat the dark lord once and for all
here's how it all goes down in the book
we'll be there Harry said Ron what at
your aunt and uncle's house said Ron and
then we'll go with you wherever you're
going no said Harry quickly he hadn't
counted on this he had meant them to
understand that he was undertaking the
most dangerous Journey alone you said it
once before said Hermione quickly that
there was time to turn back if he wanted
to we've had time haven't we we're with
you whatever happens by contrast in the
movies Ron sits laughably far away from
Hermione and Harry as the two h's plan
their future together Harry I'm not
coming back Hermione I've got to finish
whatever Dumbledore started and I don't
know where that'll lead me but I'll let
you and Ron know where I am when I can
Hermione I've always admired your
courage Harry but sometimes you can be
really thick you don't really think
you're going to be able to find all
those horcruxes by yourself do you you
need us Harry so of course with uh
enhancements like this littered
throughout the films it seems just so
obvious that Hermione should be with
Harry and certainly not that dolt Ron
all in all when it comes to the movies
I'm all for the Hermione Harry ship or
as some fans like to call them Harmony
okay maybe I wouldn't go quite that far
but with that we come to the end of
another video what did you think do you
agree should movie Hermione and Harry
have been together maybe you even think
book Hermione and Harry should have been
together or perhaps you believe that
both film and novel Ron was the right
match for Hermione let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time honestly don't
you two read
foreign